experts say that the US should test
around 4 million people every day if we
intend to track and control the virus
that is more than five times as many as
we are testing right now
well the legi got an inside look inside
Arizona's largest testing facility which
is working to rapidly increase its
capacity its capacity he's in Mesa
Arizona that's just outside Phoenix molo
good morning to you what's at stake for
people where you are well good morning
Tony you know set aside the frustrations
that some people are feeling over the
long lines that they've had to stand in
or over the inability to make an
appointment at testing sites similar to
this one right now the major testing
issue here in the state of Arizona is
getting people those test results back
quickly we're being told that it's just
not happening fast enough not enough to
make an actual difference this of course
as hospitals continue to see a crush of
patients and the virus continues to
spread and these extraordinary times we
need extraordinary solutions and we need
to be able to do that quickly dr. Brian
Kona Minh is the scientific medical
director at Sonora quest his lab handles
nearly half of all the corona virus
tests in the state of Arizona our
testing is up to about six to seven
thousand tests a day we are working on
being able to increase up to thirty to
fifty thousand tests per day after a
brief dip on Monday case number shot up
in Arizona on Tuesday with an additional
forty two hundred seventy-three new
cases reported just over 3500
hospitalizations a new record and ninety
two deaths as demand for tests has
surged in recent weeks so have the wait
times to get results at Senora quest the
average wait time for a non-priority
patient is now seven days a figure dr.
Koh diamond admits is a problem it's
testing where it needs to be in terms of
meeting the demand currently what we
want to get more testing available and
as what we're ramping up quickly to do
eventually we're gonna get down to
within a 48-hour turnaround time the
University of Arizona's student Elliot
Truslow got a test at a local CVS in
mid-june after attending a black lives
matter rally Truslow says the test was
processed by Sonora quest but the
results
much longer than seven days ultimately
how long did you wait 26 days is that
acceptable in no way shape or form is
that acceptable the availability of
thousands of tests is insignificant
without the availability of prompts test
result people are dying we followed up
with Senora quest about trust Lowe's
claim of waiting 26 days for those test
results we have yet to hear back of
course the major concern is that while
people are waiting for these test
results if they are asymptomatic perhaps
they continue to go out if they're
essential workers they continue to go to
work at a poor scale we know all the
while further spreading this virus yam
Ola and that's a problem thank you very
much